the holiday weekend travel Rush AAA is
predicting that nearly 51 million of us
in this country will be on the move that
would be a new record for the July 4th
holiday and it's despite all kinds of
delays and some Terrible Weather thrown
in as well Chris Van Cleave is in
Phoenix for us he's following all of it
Chris you got there I don't know if
other people are going to get where
they're going good morning
Good morning Tony it has really just
been a brutal week for air Travelers
weather has just been nasty and
unrelenting we're talking about more
than 45 thousand flights delayed since
Saturday more than 8 000 others canceled
the TSA and Airlines say today will be
their busiest day but they expect
airports to stay busy all the way
through next week and of course the
weather remains a giant question mark
buy land and
they're showing their independence by
being on the move for the holiday
weekend a potentially record rush out of
town
if the weather cooperates after five
days of travel troubles Denise Morales
is leaving Phoenix for a European
Vacation I am excited I've been waiting
a long time to go on this trip so it's
like exciting that like four years later
it's finally happening AAA expects 43.2
million will drive up 2.4 percent from
last year an increase helped by gas
prices that are more than a dollar 30
lower on average than this time last
year uh we're saving it yeah happy to
save as much money as we can anytime
the number of people flying for the
fourth is expected to Surge 11 over
2022. more people are feeling
comfortable traveling and that's despite
inflation it's despite High ticket
prices despite the week's paralyzing
weather disruptions Airlines have
canceled about 40 percent fewer flights
than at this point last summer but the
number of delays are up be prepared for
anything to go bad and be thrilled when
everything goes perfectly airline
industry analyst Henry hartevelt
recommends picking the airline with the
most options to where you're going take
a non-stop flight if it's available and
in your budget and try to take the first
available flight of the day those are
generally less susceptible to delays the
TSA expects to screen nearly 18 million
over the next week with Friday a
potential record breaker at checkpoints
what would you tell Flyers to reduce
their risk of disruption to their plans
yeah I tell them just a little
preparation goes a long way TSA
administrator David pakowski first thing
we're going to ask you for is
so have that ready that starts things
off on the right foot the other thing
that we see oftentimes is people have a
lot of things in their pockets United
CEO Scott Kirby offered this suggestion
be patient with everyone and try to be
nice to all your fellow travelers all of
us are going to do our best to get you
there on time and with your bags
how United says it is seeing good strong
Improvement in getting its operations
back to normal after a very rough week
for that Airline we want to end though
on some good travel news and we're going
to go across the pond some British
Airways Pilots stepped in to really save
a family's vacation take a look at this
video when Veronica Novak arrived at
London Heathrow on Tuesday she left her
purse with her passport on the plane she
flagged down
2ba Pilots they reached out to the
pilots on the plane where she left her
passport and they were able to find the
purse they dropped it out the cockpit
window as the plane was pushing back to
depart British Airways British Airways
saving that family's vacation for sure
Nate
goes to show you that good things
actually can happen when you are
traveling lucky for her Chris thank you